こんにちははじめしゃちょーです皆さんは
AIというものの進歩どれくらいご存知
でしょうか昔からなんかロボットとかAI
とかとか人工知能とかそういう言葉色々
ずっと聞いてきましたけれども最近のAI
ねまじやばいっすよネットの記事とかよく
見てる人からするともうご存知の方も結構
いるかもしれないんですけどもチャット
GPTというものがありまして
簡単に言うとすげえ実用的なAI高度な
AI技術によって人間のように人間のよう
に自然な会話ができるAIチャット
サービスそれがチャットGPTって言うん
ですよAIってさその人間らしさがないよ
とかちょっとロボットっぽいよってなんか
そういうイメージあるでしょしかし
チャットGPT何がすごいかっていうと
これ人間味のある回答が可能人間っぽい
個体してよっていうのに対応できるように
なったのがチャットGPTなんとリリース
して2ヶ月でユーザーが1億人を突破で
なんか今も性能が向上してなんか
アップデートされてるらしいんですけども
なんとですね最近
LINEの友達でチャットGPTと会話が
できるようになったらしいんですよそれを
ちょっとまずやってみましょう
今固定してるんですけどこの上のAI
チャット君っていうやつこれね話題のAI
チャットGPTをLINEで使える
チャット君ですすごくないですかどうやっ
てちょっとGPT使うんだろうっていう方
いらっしゃると思いますけども今LINE
でできるんですよ悩み事を聞いたり仕事や
文章作成を代わりに行うあなただけのAI
アシスタントです人間っぽいらしいのよ
よくわからんけど悩み事を聞いてみたり
読書感想文を書いてもらう本当かわかん
ないけどなんか大学生の卒論とかかける
らしくて人間っぽいからその見分けがつか
ないんだってチャットGPTが書いたのか
本人が書いたのか結構ねこれ世界の常識が
変わるものと言われてますちょっとGPT
お礼メールの作成とか新規事業のプレゼン
コースを作る3日分の献立今日の運勢は
占う子育て相談物事の相談はこいつでいい
んじゃないかと
そんなことないと思いたいですけどもそれ
ぐらいいろんなこと聞いてもなんか人間
っぽい彼氏ができるそしてAIなので知能
とか情報量がマジでやばいということで俺
ちょっとだけ話してみたんですよおいとか
なんかじゃんけんしようとかって話しかけ
たんですけども制限回数があるらしいので
さすがにこれ有料だよすごいもう入って
みるねこれプレミアムプラン完了しました
これで俺チャットGの話放題なのか
ちょっと話してみようこんにちは
こんにちはこんにちは私はAIの言語
モデルです何かお力になれることがあれば
遠慮なくお声かけくださいもっと
盛り上げてはい楽しいことを考えてみ
ましょう例えば好きな音楽や映画について
どうですかあるいは最近の楽しい出来事や
友達とのワクワクする計画など共有して
いただけますかまたはどんな
アクティビティが楽しいですか私も一緒に
盛り上がりたいですすごい盛り上げてと
言ったらびっくりマーク使ってくるように
なるんですよこういうとこもなんか
ちょっと人間ぽいですよね
口内炎が痛いマジです結構深刻です
口内炎は本当につらいですねたださ口内炎
に対する対処法だけじゃなくてこういう
なんかまず辛いっすねっていうねまず
気持ちを交差してくれるところがちょっと
うわーって思っちゃう薬局なので市販され
てるスプレーいや
ゼロを使用すると痛みの役立つ場合があり
ます加熱や辛味の少ない温かいスープは
ジュースなどスムージー系のものを飲む
ことも助けになるかもしれません痛みが
強い場合や3週間に続ければ社会に相談
することをお勧めしますありがとうという
ですねあのもっと色々聞いてみたいんです
けども僕が今日したいのはこんな必要ない
YouTuberはじめしゃちょー動画の
ネタ出物を常日頃考えてるんですけれども
俺ねその
爆発的に再生される時とそんな再生され
ない時があるんですよ基本的に自分がし
たいことをこうやっちゃってるんで滑る時
もあるしヒットする時もあるどういう原理
なのか俺もよく分かってなくてそれは
もちろん色んな動画再生されて欲しいよ
チャットでめっちゃ頭いいし俺とかが持っ
てない統計のデータとか情報量とか絶対
あるので今日は最先端の人工aiに
初めて社長のバズル動画聞いてみたいと
思いますこれ画期的を俺今後ネタ考えずに
ずっとチャットGPUに聞くことになるか
もしれませんからで全部再生するボカーン
そもそもYouTuber吸ってるかどう
かちょっと聞いてみますねチャットGPT
の中にYouTuberっていう言葉が
あるのかどうか
をはい私もYouTuberについて知っ
ていますYouTuberとは
YouTube上で自身が制作した
コンテンツを配信する人のことを指します
多くの人が自分の趣味や知識体験談などを
動画にして配信し多数の視聴者が彼らの
コンテンツを楽しんでいますすごいね
すごいだいたい合ってるな
YouTuberってかっこいいそもそも
こいつがYouTuberのことどう思っ
てるか俺ちょっと聞いてみるわそれによっ
てはこっちも出るとこ出ますからねを
YouTuberがかっこいいかどうかは
人それぞれの感染によって異なると思い
ますすごいね確かに一部の
YouTuberはそのスタイルや個性
業績によって尊敬を集めていますしかし
一方で一部のYouTuberは
マナーの欠如とかね不適切な表現となんか
その誰でもなれるっていうのはよくない
みたいなところもありますからね
んアルティメイトリー英語を使ってると
日本語がよくできてないところがあります
ねまあ最終的にはって感じですね最終的に
YouTuberのかっこよ視聴者
それぞれの判断に
委ねられています大正論人工知能よ人工
知能がYouTuberについて俺が
刺さって聞くとこんなに語ってくれ
るっていうこれすごいなじゃあちょっと
緊張しますけども私はじめしゃちょーに
ついて聞いてみたいと思いますこれで知ら
ないって言われたらもうこの企画終わりだ
からねマジで頼むよ聞きますよはじめしゃ
ちょーって知ってるもうこれ人工知能知ら
なかったらもう俺終わりだからさもう全然
緊張するマジでやばい手汗が
頼む
知ってるかな
はいはじめしゃちょーという
YouTuberしています彼は日本を
代表する人気YouTuberの一人で
あり
笑えて豊かな動画コンテンツを制作してい
ます彼のチャンネルでは企画や検証
チャレンジ旅行など多彩なジャンルの動画
を視聴することができますあってるねまた
彼は自らが立ち上げたエモーション
株式会社という会社を経営していることで
も知られています作ってませんモーション
株式会社はじめん株式会社なら作ってる
けどエモーション株式会社知らないぞ
ちょっと聞いてみますね
初めて株式会社じゃないのってあすみませ
ん確かにYouTuberのはじめしゃ
ちょーは自らが創設した8年間株式会社を
経営していますこの会社は
YouTuberの育成や
商材販売などを手掛けているようです
申し訳ありませんでした
商材売ってないぞまあでも初め株式会社が
何の仕事してるかって別にそんなね公に
なってないし基本的に動画作ってるだけだ
からYouTuberの育成ま畑とかね
間違
畑の存在も知ってんだなこれちゃんとあ
すみませんっていうなんか謝り方もさ
ちょっとね人間っぽいよねはじめしゃ
ちょーのこと教えてちょっと深掘りして
いきますよどこまで俺のことが知ってるの
か俺のことを知らないと俺のネタ考えられ
ないと思うので今調べてるのかな俺会社名
エモーション株式会社
[音楽]
すごいはじめしゃちょーは本名浜崎陽介
さん違うわーはじめ
浜崎陽介1988違うねえ
4月の5日いや2月14月14ちょっと
待ってなんか所々違う静岡県出身の日本
YouTuberで身長
a型彼のYouTubeチャンネルは
2011年に開設されその後多くの視聴者
を集め現在の394万人以上のチャンネル
登録者数を誇っていますもう1000万人
超えてんだけどなえー本名も生年月日
身長も血液型も違いますねちょっと修正さ
せますわあれはじめしゃちょーの本名始め
て身長186cmだよここら辺しっかりし
て問題ないとちょっとね
おっしゃる通りです私の回答に誤りがあり
ました調べてみるとはじめしゃちょーの
本名は
ダムと
まだはじめははじめコーポレーションと
いう
株式会社も経営しているということで知ら
れています申し訳ありませんでしたま
たまに言われますけど始めですし初めに
株式会社もなんかひねりひねってはじめ
コーポレーションになっちゃってるな
怒るよ経営してるなら始めん株式会社だよ
んいや俺ははじめコーポレーションも
はじめパブリッシングも
設立したことないけどなちょっと名前だけ
ちゃんと訂正してもらおうかなさすがに
漢字が違う
めっちゃ俺怒ってる人みたいじゃん
めちゃくちゃたち悪い人みたいあいや俺枝
始めという名前で活動していたことを1回
もないけどなでもすごいねこうやってミス
を受け入れて自分で修正していくのが
チャットGPTなのかな俺さよく始めんっ
て言われるんですけどもこれ始めんって
伝わるのかな色んな人初めて言われてそう
だからわかんないんだろうなえ始めという
呼び方は独自のファンコミュニティが
作り出した故障ではじめしゃちょーさんが
自身で推奨しているわけではありません
一部のファンたちがTwitterや
YouTubeなどで始めると呼び合って
いるようですが公式の呼び方というわけで
はありません
マジだなんか間違いはもちろんあります
けどもはじめんっていう言葉のその使われ
方とかまでわかってるの結構キモくない
ですかはじめしゃちょーの動画見たって
ちょっと聞いてみましょうかはいはじめ
しゃちょーさんの動画を何本か見たことが
ありますまずいAI俺の動画見てるの
ありがとうこれでわかったことが1つある
チャットGPTは俺の動画を見たことが
あるそしてとても面白く楽しめる内容だと
いうことも分かっているつまりこいつに
聞けば俺の今後の動画のネタを考えて
くれるのではないかとちょっと踏み込んで
聞いてみましょうはじめしゃちょーの
面白かった動画はそれバチン答えられたら
俺は結構ね
信頼しますよ今後俺のネタ会議の相棒とし
て頑張ってもらおうえはじめしゃちょー
さんの面白い動画を数多くありますか私が
もうおすすめの動画をいくつか紹介します
12年前に撮ったコント動画が炎上して
しまった自分で動画
撮りすぎてこれ本当に撮ったのか覚えて
ない
の12年前
ギリギリYouTubeやってないね宇宙
からの脱出俺宇宙行ったことないけどな
これもない
どれ一つやってないぞ
やってるんじゃないかまあまあまあまあ
まだわかんないまだわかんない何がの
間違いかもしれない変顔ミスだきっと
そんな動画ないよってさあどうかです
[音楽]
新しい回答が来た緊急事態食べるのやめ
ましたはじめしゃちょーさんが食べ物を
食べることやめるという企画の動画です
健康に対する真剣な考え方や強い意志を
持って目標に取り組む女性が印象的な内容
ですファジーとかしてた時のことなのかな
家飛び越えましたを作ったはじめしゃ
ちょーさんが家の2階から外に出るための
家飛び越えマシンを作成する様子が描かれ
た動画でこの工程は実際に飛び越える
ところが非常に面白いです
し実は涙の背負い投げ泣きながら背負い
投げしたこともないよひょっとしたら
はじめしゃちょーっていうものの知識が
そんなにないのかもしれないし
申し訳ありません以前の回答に誤りがあり
ましたおすすめのはじめしゃちょーさんの
動画としてはモノマネしたら放送事故に
なるの知ってたHIKAKINとドッキリ
抜き打ち会見やってみたいやったことない
よそんなの内容としたらHIKAKINと
のコラボや放送事故を意識してのモノマネ
だそういや俺モノマネとかもできないから
ねちょっと俺のこと勘違いしてるな俺の
こと勘違いしてるな俺ははじめしゃちょー
本人大変失礼いたしましたおっしゃる通り
私はあなたの発言を公開していました
申し訳ありませんでしたはじめしゃちょー
さんの動画では世界一危ない音が
セクシャルハラスメントをしたらこうなる
や事故物件決戦歌うま祭りの撮影現場で
潜入してみたら全部やったことないネタ
聞く前にいろんなネタができてきとるな何
言ってんの世界一危ない男がセクシャで
ハラスメントをしたらこうなるライブ
センシティブな話題だよちょっと言っとき
ますがはじめしゃちょーのこともっと勉強
しといてって俺世界じゃない男が
セクシャルハラスメントしたらこうなる
やりませんからありがとう最後に1つ聞き
たいんだがいいかなはい何が質問があり
ましたらお気軽にお聞きくださいお答え
いたしますじゃあ聞きますよはい聞きまし
たはじめしゃちょーがバズリストの企画を
考えてもストレートにこれも皆さんすごい
ですよ聞く前から色んなネタくれたし
だいぶやばいのお来たはじめしゃちょーの
企画としては24時間ずっとはみ出す
ナンバーガールと世界一周3日間
極寒の中で生き抜くなどが考えられます
[音楽]
またはじめしゃちょーさんが得意とする
ゲームを使った企画も人気があるんで
Minecraftでモノマネタレントを
作るというなアイディアも面白いかもしれ
ません
マインクラフトしたことない
ナンバーガールって何だナンバーガールっ
てバンドがいるけどもう2022年の12
月で解散してますね3日間極寒の中で生き
抜くはちょっとコスパが悪いなちょっとコ
スパのことを伝えてなかったですコスト
パフォーマンスが良くてはじめしゃちょー
しそうな企画は労力たくさんかけて時間
たくさんかけたらバツイそうな企画きっと
出てくると思うんですけどももっとこうね
家とかでパッとできて俺の発想の上を行く
ような企画考えてくれたらちょっと嬉しい
ですねを来た来た来た来たありがとう
ございますコストパフォーマンさんが言っ
てはじめしゃちょーの企画には以下のよう
なものが考えられます100円ショップ
チャレンジ
具体的なやり方まで書いてくれてる
100円ショップで購入したグッズを使っ
て
面白く役に立つコンテンツを作る企画
アバウトやな折り紙チャレンジビデオ内で
折り紙の構造を交えながら視聴者と一緒に
折り紙で目標物を作る企画
一人で野球観戦はじめしゃちょーさんが
1人で野球観戦に行く企画ゲストを呼ぶ
必要がないので
低コストで制作可能ですなるほどねWBC
面白かったからなちょっとこれはありだな
家族で過ごす休日はじめしゃちょーさんが
家族と一緒に過ごす休日を撮影する企画
自宅での収録なのでコストもかからず家族
愛をテーマにした動画が人気ですなるほど
なるほど1人野球観戦とか家族に
フォーカス当てた動画俺あんまり少なかっ
たりするからうわそれめっちゃやりたいっ
ていう企画はないけどヒントとしては
かなり大きいものをもらいましたちょっと
意地悪してみようかなはじめ社長が絶対
バトル企画を教えてこれはもうだいぶ
ハードル高いですよなかなかこの動画作る
上で絶対バズるとかってなかなか言い
づらいと思うんですけどもあえてそれを
すごい知識になるチャットGPT聞いてみ
たいと思いますそれ答えられたらすごいぞ
だいぶ重宝してるな考えてくれてるのかな
これ
[音楽]
うわぁめっちゃ正しいことはまず最初に
添えてるはじめしゃちょーが絶対にバズる
企画は今後のトレンドで社会情勢によって
変わってくるかもしれません確かにね昔
だったらバズってたものが今バズらないと
かあるからタイミング次第では以下は一流
ですボタンスライダーコース作り水を張っ
た斜面にジャンプ台でトンネルを設置して
ウォータースライダーコースを作り始め
社長さんが滑走していく様子を撮影する家
でやったらバズるね多分ちょっとね
ウォータースライダー
作ったとかだるいんだよなぁ動画のこと
だけ考えてるからね巨大ダンスゲーム大型
なパネルに表示されるダンスゲームに
合わせてはじめしゃちょーさんが挑戦する
視聴者がゲーム進行状況を見ながらはじめ
しゃちょーさんのダンスに合わせて応援
するうーん外国人YouTuberとの
交流英語が得意なはじめしゃちょーさんが
世界中の有名なYouTuberと交流
する様子また日本の文化や料理を紹介する
企画新しいですよねあんなに俺英語喋る
とこ見せてないし
バズるのかな通りすがりの人にダンスを
教えるはじめしゃちょーさんが通りすがり
の人たちにダンスをして一緒に踊る様子を
撮影していくまた視聴者から踊ってほしい
ダンスを募集してはじめしゃちょーダンス
できる人だと思ってるダンスまったくでき
ないんです僕逆にそれが面白いみたいだね
最後5番同然の動物と触れ合う企画動物園
ではじめしゃちょーさんが動物と触れ合う
様子を撮影する可愛い動物たちとの
ふれあいを楽しむ様子や動物たちの
素晴らしい能力や知識を視聴者に伝える
ことができます
自分で考えよう
[音楽]